okay hello everyone welcome to another
science and technology history q a
and i'm happy to try and answer
questions about uh either history that
i've been involved in of science and
technology
or
more ancient history
uh even given how ancient i am
but even more ancient history
that i might know something about
so there was a question here
from amy asking
are you familiar with norbert weiner's
work
is it relevant to current computer
science at all
okay so now we know
i always used to refer to him as the
patron saint of mit
um i think he was mit is probably mit's
first really famous professor
and he
uh perhaps that's unfair but but he had
been kind of a a child prodigy type in
the
uh early 1900s
and um
he uh kind of was in mathy kinds of
things
and um
did uh
uh then
i think he got involved in
in various kinds of um
more well i don't know social causes and
things like this but i think he you know
his early work was on uh mathematical
kinds of things and on um
uh i think functional analysis basically
um
but uh
then in
not quite sure i know the full sequence
of this but in world war ii
he was involved uh with um
um automatic anti-aircraft guns
and i guess the main issue is if you
have a sensor that is um
detecting where a plane is and you have
a gun and it's going to fire a fire some
shell and the shell takes certain amount
of time to to um
to travel and the plane is going at a
certain speed and so on you have to do a
bunch of things you have to kind of make
a controller that will make certain
predictions based on some model of the
world about kind of where to point the
gun to to do what you want to do or
whatever and um
so
we know was involved in this kind of um
idea about control
and how to make automated control
systems and and so on
um i think that the
uh that got him into
this area that he called cybernetics i
believe that was his name uh comes from
the um uh latin word gubernator which
means a helmsman and it's been it's an
interesting example of of sort of word
minting
in in science where it was you know in
in latin it's gub et cetera but that
turned into cyn
um uh
cyb rather and that has led to all of
our cyber this that and the other all
came from that that term
which which kind of came out of um this
so the the the field that became of
interest was this sort of how do you
control things
what is what is kind of a control system
a system where
um
one has
certain
uh input from the world
one is then going to
uh one has control of some system and
one has to have it sort of agree with
what's happening in the world classic
example something like a thermostat
where it's measuring the temperature of
the room
it decides when it gets too cold it says
okay switch on the heater but it can
easily overshoot because the heater gets
switched on but it takes a certain
amount of time for the room to heat up
and then even if you switch the heater
off the there's uh it might take some
time for it to
cool down things like that
and so there are these different
strategies uh we have a bunch of them
implemented in waltham language simplest
as so-called pid controllers are a
typical approach to doing that but
there's a whole theory of how to set up
that kind of control and there's a whole
the big there are all these questions
about whether you have whether something
is controllable that is it could be the
case that the time that it takes the the
thermostat and the heater and so on to
respond is just such that the system
isn't controllable you can't make it
maintain a fixed temperature or if you
have an airplane with an autopilot you
can't make it maintain a fixed altitude
because things are changing in such a
way that it you you could never you
never successfully achieve that kind of
control
so there was this whole area that
became of interest to do with
controlling systems and
the
there was the idea of controlling
machines and also the idea of well is
this also the way that animals and
humans do control
and this field of cybernetics
got started and we know was a key
contributor to that and it was kind of
he wrote a book called cybernetics what
was it called i think the subtitle is
something like um
oh something about control in
animals and machines some such other
thing i remember reading that book i
have to admit i haven't read it in i did
read that book um back when i was a kid
probably
1975-ish time scale that book was
probably written originally
in the 1950s i think
um
i remember that that book kind of um
talks a lot about
i think it even has a sort of as an
opening description it talks about a
piece of history
uh to do with edison i noticed
somebody's asked about tesla so we'll
talk about edison as well
um the uh
uh a story of when when um when edison
was first introducing electric power so
the big demo
uh that edison did of electric power
and um and light bulbs and so on was uh
what was it pearl street in new york
city a small street where it was
electrified and um
he had these generators that were
supposed to be running and he had two
generators and the story that i think we
know told is based on my memory from a
long time ago so so one could check this
but i think this is what was in the
cybernetics book
the story was edison had two generators
and he had them running
at different speeds
and
the the way that he had them both
running together they're both connected
together and the initial way that these
generators were connected was such that
they repelled in phase so as one of them
would run one way the other one would be
more and more out of phase with that
first generator and this caused a
disaster and one of them started running
faster the other one's slower and they
were about to explode and edison figured
out some some hack to fix that
um and it turns out that as i think
wiener pointed out in that book there is
a way of controlling of connecting those
those generators those oscillators
together so that they will attract in
phase if i remember what's in that book
he talks about that in connection with
with brain waves eeg and human brains
and so on and the possibility that those
mechanisms for sort of generating a
frequency and maintaining the frequency
might be the same
anyway so
there was this whole idea of cybernetics
sort of how do you do control
in machines as a practical matter how do
you do kind of that in how do animals do
control of things
and
this this became a popular field so this
is 1950s
and uh the particular thing that was
sort of a focal point for that with
these so-called macy conferences um yes
that's the macy's department store um
that was a philanthropy at the time that
supported scientific causes
and um
there were these series of macy
conferences
that featured uh well so so the sort of
big fields of the time
were you know psychiatry was kind of in
its psychology that turned into sort of
psychoanalysis freudian type stuff
turning into psychiatry that was kind of
the
the super popular hot field of the 1950s
in terms of lots of kinds of science
um
and
that was that was uh something which was
a dominant theme in this cybernetics
movement and so warren mcculloch who was
a
psychiatrist who um uh was also the
person along with walter pitts who kind
of invented the standard model of neural
nets back in 1943 or so um and uh he was
a big figure in these macy conferences
as were people like margaret mead the
anthropologist
and a variety of other
kinds of people in these kind of
psychological type sciences
um and
but
what came out of that cybernetics
discussion was a lot of kind of more
psychological kinds of things but there
was kind of also a branch that was more
on the kind of uh kind of hard computer
science side and that was eventually uh
people like marvin minsky and john
mccarthy and so on who were the early
people involved in kind of the ai world
so for a while there was kind of the the
the macy conferences about cybernetics
and so on uh there were also another
collection of people people like um
heinz von foster
and um there was this uh a whole
collection of people who were interested
in studying kind of the the
control in organisms
um as a way to understand biology there
was this idea of homeostasis a person
called ross ashby who is big on this
this notion of homeostasis how do how do
organisms keep like let's say our body
temperature how do we maintain that how
is that um what is the control mechanism
for that and that became this whole sort
of branch of investigation
um
and
the thing so
along alongside all of that were the
people studying essentially turing
machines and kind of the more thinking
side of as an ai intelligency thinking
side of kind of how how organisms work
and kind of the notion perhaps was well
there's this kind of control systems but
then there's this higher level control
system which is the whole brain and its
whole assembly and so on
i think
the um how did that all evolve
well
the kind of we're going to solve biology
so by the way
that was a time so biology has never
been a terribly theoretical field
there aren't
most of the time most of biology
consists of you go and observe the
organism you go and do the experiment
you know it is not for us to have a
theory type thing is the often the point
of view
there were a few
kind of efforts in theoretical biology
and they had some interaction with the
whole cybernetics world so there'd been
people like um darcy went with thompson
back in the
1917 and he wrote this book called on
growth and form which i uh um did a
whole study of it at its um at centenary
um and he then had a second edition of
it in 1942 i think um on growth and form
is kind of a story of how
uh the kind of um geometrical forms that
arise in physical systems have
correspondences in in biology that's
it's that's kind of a big piece of of
that story it's not a very mathematical
approach it's not uh about equations and
things like that
meanwhile in theoretical biology back in
those days there have been a few sort of
equation-y type things that have come in
like for example the lot covaltera
equations for population biology um
they'd been a thing
um there were places where people were
starting to study uh things like
epidemiology
notably
okay here's a piece of a micro footnote
to history
um
a uh
the original
um
people in in the in the time of the
pandemic
people have been talking a lot about
epidemiological models and in particular
about sir models um susceptible infected
recovered um three different uh sort of
types of
of of agents in the model
with differential equations that
describe their rate of infection and
things like this
um those models were originally the they
were called the comac mckendrick models
and um in a piece of uh
of utter footnote trivia a very good
friend of mine in in high school was a
person named nicholas comac who was the
grandson of the of the william ogilvie
kermit i think who had been the original
um
uh
well chemistry he mostly was and
biologist who in
1910-ish i think had proposed this comic
mckendrick model that became our modern
sir model um it's sort of interesting to
read the original paper
about this because it's very tentative
and it has by the way the the best data
i'm not sure if it was already in that
paper it was in subsequent paper some
some british boarding school um had
epidemiological data on on kids getting
sick and that was kind of the the
earliest validation of that um uh that
kind of model but the first paper is
very tentative about you know well this
might work it might not really work as a
model i i find it interesting that as
time rolls forward people have kind of
built on top of that model um and uh and
had it become almost the definitive
model even though it made many
compartments rather than just the the
susceptible it might be people and you
know who mix with this set of people and
so on i actually think these models are
are fairly inadequate um and it's very
difficult to get a more accurate kind of
more social network based model of
what's actually going on the data
doesn't exist and uh even if you collect
the data there are just many many other
factors but it's just that was a that
was one of the early pieces of sort of
mathematical type biology
what happened to um
then there were
there were a variety of other sort of
cybernetic inspired um efforts in
theoretical biology as a person called
conrad waddington who was a
british person who had this idea he
called it uh canalization
things going into canals effectively
things where you would be sort of it's
an early notion of attractors attractors
were also the idea that um have been
critical in what's turned into machine
learning and all those kinds of things
um that was also in a sense the
homeostasis idea is also an early
attractor idea um and you know talking
about attractors attractors there's this
notion where let's say i don't know in a
very simple case you might have a let's
say you have a
a sort of a um
a track for a ball that's kind of a
u-shaped track and the ball is running
backwards and forwards on the track and
gradually under friction the thing will
go to the sort of a tractor where the
ball is sitting at the bottom of the
track that's a very simple case
but there are more complicated cases
where the attractor is not just a fixed
point but instead it's a limit cycle the
thing goes to a
tends to have a kind of a
tends to go to something where it is
going in a fixed cycle that's what
happens in the luck of all terror
equations that describe this kind of
predator prey interaction where you can
get sort of periodic um
uh uh
oscillations in the population of this
kind of creature versus that kind of
creature and so on and then the thing
that was discovered
well it started to be discovered in the
early 1900s by people like pancreas but
it kind of really emerged in prominence
in the 1950s and 1960s
was the idea of strange attractors where
instead of the thing evolving to
something where it's just always
periodic it evolves to something that
has much more random chaotic behavior um
exactly what the origins of that are
i've done a whole bunch of work on that
and we could talk about that let's not
get off into that that topic um but uh
in any case the the main sort of
development from from cybernetics was
various kinds of attractor type things
mostly fixed points a few limit cycles
they didn't know about strange
attractors and that was kind of the
development in the 1950s of cybernetics
now the whole idea of we're going to
solve theoretical biology and there's
going to be some sort of current some
sort of correlated solution to the ai
problem and the problem of how animals
move and all these other problems and
the problems of how we maintain you know
body temperature and so on the idea of
sort of a grand unified theory of that
didn't really pan out
what instead happened was that control
theory the kind of the mathematical
theory of how to build mechanisms that
could maintain control of something that
branched off as its own field and became
a very mathematical area of engineering
for some reason particularly widely
practiced in the scandinavian countries
like particularly sweden was particular
leader in kind of control systems um
mathematics and
uh and so on but that had been a that
was a thing that um that kind of
branched off from cybernetics it became
an area of engineering it's a it's a
well-studied area it has all kinds of
complicated uh issues and when you're
starting to make drones and all kinds of
things that need all kinds of nonlinear
control it still has many uh sort of
research frontiers today but very much
in the engineering mathematics kind of
area
meanwhile the other aspects of
cybernetics um one of them was this kind
of notion of
sort of biological
control and so on
and really
i think that turned into a few different
things
so one field of of biology where
differential equations work to some
extent at least is endocrinology
and um
there was some work although not a huge
amount
where people were using the kinds of
cybernetics-like techniques to figure
out things about
you know you release one hormone it does
this and that causes this to be released
and you can write down differential
equations that describe those kinds of
things
not a huge area but but that was a sort
of surviving area and i think
the the other piece of the whole thing
was the kind of whole ai
uh you know make artificial intelligence
that went through many different uh ups
and downs the the kind of branching off
from control of animals and so on
the people who worked on that ended up
being well the people who were connected
to those conferences at least ended up
being some of the people who sort of
took the turing machine idea and the
neural net idea which were two sort of
related idealizations of computation um
and kind of moved those forward and
tried to understand things about that
and this is going into the 1960s
which was the first sort of period of
great enthusiasm for the ai so i think
the answer is that that sort of
cybernetics
uh weiner's main sort of area of um
uh
of um of energy there was some um
uh you know it branched off control
theory which is a very real thing
the idea that it was sort of going to
solve theoretical biology and solve ai
didn't really pan out and instead those
went on their own separate kinds of ways
so that's at least um
uh
my my main comment i mean there there
are pieces of wearness work is
mathematical work wiener integrals and
things like this
okay that's a whole different
story and i'm now remembering this a
little bit
uh so one of the things that we now
worked on was
random walks
so random walk means
you just say at every at every moment
you're going to take a step in a random
direction and you move around and you'll
roughly uh after in in after a time t if
you take t steps you the average
distance you've gone is roughly square
root of t and the distribution is
roughly a gaussian kind of distribution
that you reach in that random walk
and people studied random walks for a
variety of different reasons um one of
the first places where i've seen a
random walk actually shown was in a book
by john venn
inventor of venn diagrams
i think that book was around 1850 that
kind of time frame it's kind of a
curious thing because he draws a
two-dimensional random walk and the way
he gets his random numbers is from the
digits of pi
so it's kind of interesting because in
modern times we talk about pseudorandom
generators and can we have an algorithm
for generating randomness but
and we
so far as from that time until now
nobody has found a kind of statistical
pattern in the digits of pi but that was
a place where john van used that as his
basis for making a random walk
random walks then was sort of noticed by
what was the name robert brown i think
was the person who discovered brownian
motion
uh seeing pollen grains kind of kicked
around this was a time before people
knew that atoms were a real thing i
think 1830s maybe um was uh uh just
observing through a microscope pollen
grains
in in in water or something and the
noticing that they just get kicked every
so often
as a result of that they're light enough
that a single molecular collision is
capable of kicking them a bit
and that that is this brownian motion
and that was one of the there were two
main pieces of evidence for the
existence of atoms one was bound in
motion the other was all the work done
by people like dalton on chemistry and
the fact that there were these chemical
reaction equations where things worked
out
if you assume that there were sort of
integer numbers of different kinds of
atoms there as opposed to just
continuous amounts of material but any
case
so brownian motion the kicking around of
pollen grains was another place where
they ran and walks
another one louis bashelier i think in
the around 1900
um
was um
uh noticing that the the prices in the
paris stock market
were sort of bouncing up and down
according to a random walk so if a price
was a particular value today so to speak
it had a certain chance of going up in a
certain chance of going down and so that
was a a thing that um uh that was looked
at then albert einstein uh wrote a
famous paper about brownian motion uh
trying to analyze
the um
uh
its behavior and so on um that was maybe
even 1905 maybe that was the same year
as the relativity paper i'm not sure
around that time at least
but in any case into that whole story
came weiner
somewhat later and the main issue is if
you've got this random walk what is the
trajectory it makes you know people have
studied geometrically they've studied
things like straight lines they've
studied circles things like that but
this walk this random walk where
something's being jiggled around all the
time and potentially it's being jiggled
uh the the next jiggle can happen
infinitesimally soon after after the
previous one or alternatively you can
just zoom out and you can say what is
this path that this random walk follows
so
wiener got involved in trying to analyze
that um and this is what leads to things
like weiner integrals and we know
measure and so on um that uh
are about random walks
the theory of random walks um
is is critical in understanding things
about uh quantitative finance and so on
because it is a pretty good
approximation as um this louis bachelier
chap noticed around 1900 that the prices
of of stocks roughly follow around and
walk it's not exactly a random walk it's
not exactly a gaussian distribution it
tends to have a heavy tail and it and
also you know you don't go below zero
because the price of a stock at least
you know if the company is is is worth
less than zero the company it doesn't
exist so to speak so there's it's not
quite a gaussian distribution and the
deviations have huge consequences but in
a first approximation it's like that and
then you have to ask questions like
given that things are wiggling around in
this random walk what can you say about
the probability of different kinds of
things happening so very common cases is
options where you say you know i'll i'll
give you x amount for the option to buy
this stock at a given price at a certain
point in the future and so the question
is what is the expected
value of that option and that's
something you can compute by assuming uh
that if you assume that the stock has a
random walk that has a certain
volatility a certain rate of sort of
wiggling up and down
and perhaps a certain overall trend and
so on you can compute
what that sort of expected might not
actually be what happens it's just a
probability you can compute for example
what the most likely or the uh expected
um value of that option should be and
that was what led to things like the
black shoals model when was that
1970-ish
but and it also led to a thing that was
an outgrowth of weiner's work which is a
thing called the ito calculus
which was
where the basic idea is
you normally use study differential
equations and we mentioned differential
equations in connection with the biology
in connection with epidemiology and so
on differential equations are telling
you
the
uh this the rate of change of this thing
depends on the amount of this other
thing
and the the sort of the the classic
differential equation is something like
radioactive decay
where the rate of of atoms decaying is
proportional to the number of atoms that
that exist
and that gives you an exponential decay
but
the the idea that comes about with
random walks is stochastic differential
equations where instead of saying the
rate of change of this thing is
proportional to some other quantity that
you can just to write down the quantity
you say the rate of change of the thing
is given by some random variable that's
wiggling around randomly and then you
ask questions about so what do the
solutions to those kinds of equations
look like and that's something which has
uh has a uh has sort of a a piece in the
kind of quantitative finance ito
calculus area has a peace and control
theory because control theory one's
often interested in i'm trying to
control this plane and keep it at a
fixed altitude even though there's a
certain amount of buffeting of sort of
random wind that sort of noise kicking
the plane around
um and those are
those are places where
uh
those are those are two places where
this kind of notion of of stochastic
calculus
uh shows up um and uh let's see i think
there's a
i was going to mention a um
um
a third one but it uh escaped my mind
here
um
um
let's see i'm not sure um
in any case so that's some
um a uh
uh yeah okay so so this also shows up in
quantum mechanics and a bunch of other
places you're interested in these same
kinds of integrals where solving
differential equations where you have
these these um uh these random uh sort
of sources of randomness in them so
anyway the answer is oh yeah i know what
i was going to say the the um uh in
control theory the big issue is feedback
loops and that was a big piece of the
cybernetics story and actually that led
to two other things which i might
mention one was general systems theory
and another was uh
systems theory i think it's called um
these were two sort of approaches that
were kind of the idea was general
systems theory was going to be a theory
of kind of how
well how systems behave and it was
supposed to be applied to large-scale
economic systems maybe social systems
all kinds of systems
there was a
systems theory became another branch a
little bit different i think from
general systems theory particularly
notable contributor though a person
called jay forrester who's also the
person who invented core memory for
computers a long-term uh mit orbit
person i met him a few times um and uh
this kind of systems theory thing was
some sort of systems thinking was kind
of a one of the core ideas was this
notion of feedback loops this notion
that
something happens and there is feedback
from the consequences of that happening
that affects how the system will behave
going forward and the idea in in terms
of this control theory thing the idea is
that feedback loops are what allow you
to have sort of a stable control of
something
okay so
the um uh what i was going to mention
was that in control theory there's a
whole theory of feedback loops and and
the consequences of feedback loops and
that's all tied into stochastic calculus
and so on needless to say and like many
ideas these things get reinvented so
reinforcement learning in machine
learning is the same idea as these
feedback loops
and the whole mechanism of feedback
loops and the discussion of feedback
loops and control systems has sort of
been rediscovered and reinvented in the
context of reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is you kind of
have a
a machine learning system and it's
trying to play a video game let's say
and it tries doing something and then it
sees what happens in the world of the
video game and then it feeds back and
that feeds back into the sort of
learning of the machine learning system
it's the same idea as what happens in
control systems played out in a new
context with a different name
so that's a bit of a summary on uh
what i can at least remember of of
norbert weiner's different uh
involvements
okay let's um
uh
um
[Music]
huh okay
um
well
all right there are all kinds of
questions here a lot of questions about
have i met this person that person so
aaron asks by having stories about fred
brooks and the mythical man month
um and when did i read it so i've
certainly met fred brooks i i suspect
he's not alive anymore but but
i i didn't know him well but i certainly
met him um
the mythical man month is a
is a is a book that fred brooks wrote
out of his experiences at ibm
he was involved in creating the
operating system for the ibm 360
mainframe computer
and it was a big software project
and the question
that came up was
well you know in a lot of kinds of work
if you want to like dig a ditch
then
supposedly the theory is if you have
more workers digging the ditch the ditch
will get dug faster
and so the notion was well that's going
to work for everything including for
example for software systems
and
let's just throw more people on the
project was kind of an ibm idea
and
what fred brooks discovered realized
whatever from managing this project is
that was a that just didn't work for
software project it didn't really work
to just throw more throw more people at
the problem
now and the mythical man month i i think
was a was a um
you know a response to that observation
of software projects don't have the
scaling property that things often have
and i remember
um
at the time i i don't know whether this
is some
uh
uh i don't know what the current story
of this is but it used to be said that
the average programmer writes four lines
of code per day
um just as i recall uh and what did that
actually mean well it meant on one day
somebody write a hundred lines of code
but then they'd spend the next hour many
days debugging what they'd written
um
and uh you know this was in the days
when people were writing everything in
assembly language when debugging was a
very non-trivial activity when the cycle
for debugging was long
and i think there's a question of you
know how has this evolved over time
clearly one of the big objectives of
many of the of the standard programming
languages has been the management of
sort of complexity of programs so to
speak whether it's object-oriented
programming whether it's some
various kinds of of approaches to the
the sort of uh i don't know the source
control systems you know cvs git
whatever else all these kinds of things
they're all pieces of kind of this
attempt to control the complexity of the
programs that are getting written
as well as dealing with the fact that
there are often larger teams working on
them
i mean my own
uh i suppose
uh you know one of one of the issues is
are you writing an assembly language are
you writing in a language which
fundamentally is pretty low level in
terms of what it's describing or are you
writing in a language which is very high
level and really the issue is at what
stage in that did the designer of the
language insert themselves you know is
it a low-level language where the
designer of the language said i'm just
going to give you a few basic tools and
then i'm out of here and you know maybe
you're using libraries somebody else
created or something like that but the
language is not defining sort of a a a
high level framework for how you how you
describe things my objective with
wolfram language over what's now
basically 40 years
has been to create this kind of
high-level full-scale computational
language which allows you to actually
describe things in the world and things
you want to do in as higher level form
as form as close to the way that you as
a human think about these things as
possible that's a somewhat different
objective than the programming languages
have had but the programming languages
have had kind of the idea
of manage large scale given that you're
writing big long programs and you have
to write big long programs because the
programming language itself doesn't
provide you with very much
um you know make that as easy as
possible and there are clearly many many
different things that have come in
whether it's continuous integration for
for continuous testing of things and
whether it's um the uh the sort of the
practices for you know the waterfall
method the agile method all these kinds
of management type practices that have
come in to try and manage software
projects these are all sort of uh they
all in some sense merge together i think
in the in the fred brooks mythical man
month idea i would say that probably it
is the it is the the the long time sort
of ancestor of a bunch of these modern
uh kind of approaches to managing
software projects now i have to say
in in my own experience
different software projects which have
different characters and should be
managed in different ways when you're
creating things like user interfaces
that's a very you know one piece gets
done one piece gets done it's all sort
of pieces when you're creating kind of
algorithmic code it works in a different
way uh some sort of special cases of
things like natural language
understanding code like we have for
wolfman alpha which has a bizarre
non-modularity i mean one of the issues
is can you develop one piece of code
over here completely independent from
this other team over here and then have
them integrate together properly part of
making that possible is good language
design and and we've achieved that
pretty well
in the pieces of orphan language that
people can work on some component of the
language and they can be really quite
independent of people working on some
other component you know image
processing versus statistics or
something um and uh versus i don't know
cloud uh
cloud process execution or something
like that but because there's a strong
language design and a strong framework
they can all be confident that the
things they've built if they follow
these design principles will fit
together um and that's something that is
sort of achieved by having kind of a a
high-level full-scale computational
language
uh
let's see
it's a question from hts here
um
about uh my opinion on john bakkus's
lecture from 1977
can programming be liberated from von
neumann style
uh
yeah i can't claim to know that paper
tremendously well um the the kind of the
von neumann style is this kind of idea
of procedural programming where you say
i define the state of my program by the
by values of by variables
and those variables in early computers
and today as well
are represent things stored in the
memory of the computer i name this thing
that i'm storing here in the memory of
the computer x i name this other thing y
and then the way that i do operations on
things is by
saying i have a series of instructions i
execute one instruction after another
and then i have various kinds of jumps
where i say when i if this happens then
execute this other instruction here or
another instruction there and that's
kind of the the you know sort of the
flow chart model of how to think about
computation and flow charts were a thing
that was
they've been introduced in the 1920s i
think
by um
i think by frank and lillian gilbreth
who were early kind of time in motion
people so the thing they were interested
in was people have factories and the
question is how do you organize the
production line for factory what do you
do you know in other words what you
don't want to have happen is there's a
production line and there's one person
who is you know
uh sort of assembling the top of the
box you're making or whatever it is
and everybody else has done their part
but there's a hold up at that place on
the production line and there's also the
question of when that person is going to
you know put the top on the box
you know how do they get the you know do
they get the parts they have to walk
over to the other side of the factory to
get the parts and then walk back again
and that's all very inefficient or is it
the case that they just you know reach
out their right hand and pick up that
piece and put it in their left hand and
do this and and very efficiently able to
assemble the thing so that turned into
in i think the 1920s uh this notion of
time in motion study and there were
these people who became sort of time and
motion experts where they would take you
know early movies and things of people
doing things in factories and they would
show oh if you rearrange this and put
this this container here and move that
to there and so on then you can greatly
improve the efficiency of people working
in in factories
um and that turned into i think this
sort of more formal analysis of that
turned into flowcharts
uh frank and lily and gilbreth were were
perhaps more famous to history
for the fact that um they had a large
number of children and one of their
children wrote a book called cheaper by
the dozen
which is basically about um
uh i think the um uh
those two as parents were at least
reputed to have been so efficiency
oriented that they realized that if they
only had you know more than 12 children
they would get all these discounts from
a dozen of things and so on i'm not sure
if that's completely correct but um
there's been a couple of movies uh
made based on that cheaper by the dozen
book um that portray various different
forms of of um
of things happening related to that but
anyway that was the you know this early
time in motion sort of factory
efficiency thing what led to flowcharts
flow charts were then reused by von
neumann and so on in the uh
late 1940s early 1950s
as um
uh as kind of the the pattern for how to
describe how to program a computer that
it's like do this step do that step to
that step and importantly maintain
information you have two pieces of
information you have what step are you
on
as you walk through the flow chart and
you have the values of variables
now in my own view
that's a very hard thing for people to
really wrap their well the step by step
by step that's okay people people do
okay with that all these variables that
sort of hang out all over the place all
around your computer and it's like did i
really have a variable called x here did
i really have one called that it's very
it's very uncontrolled
when you think about functional
programming the idea of functional
programming being you have a thing and
you apply functions to it
that's a much in a sense feels to me a
much more contained controlled you can
wrap your brain around it kind of thing
because the whole thing you're operating
on is right there
and that's that's kind of a an
alternative to this idea of you're
storing state and all these variables
hanging out all over your computer i
mean the most extreme versions of that
were things like in fortran for example
early language from the 1950s um fortran
ended up at least when i used it in the
in the 1970s
um early 70s um
this this whole thing of of um
uh
the um you know where the variables are
stored and so on had gotten way out of
control there were these things called
common blocks which were ways of taking
variables in one file and making them in
common to another file and so on and i
remember somebody telling me you know
the key problem of programming is the
management of common blocks
um which kind of is already as soon as
you you hear something like that you
know this is a sort of problem area but
any case the i think john backus's point
um
and i i i was you know can one do things
with functional programming and instead
of in particular in the sort of
flowchart way of doing things it's like
you do this you do this you do this if
something happens
then uh
then do that instead and it's it's all
very much a um
um
uh
sorry i'm just trying to rearrange this
okay
um it's all very much um
the um
uh
um
something that um
uh
i'm sorry i'm confused by
by
um
times here okay the um the the this
this question of is do you
control sort of the flow of um uh
of things
by
um
um
but by by just saying
do this step through this step to this
step or is it more this function is
going to be applied then this function
is going to be applied then this
function is going to be applied and
there isn't a program counter that was
the kind of that's the low-level
mechanism in computers that says which
piece of code is about to be executed
next is it really the direct control of
the program counter where you say if
such and such if x is greater than zero
go to
such and such which means you know just
reset the value of the program counter
and start executing another piece of
code or is it more you execute the
series of functions and that's the way
that you sort of maintain the flow of
both control and the flow of data and so
on
and uh that's you know i'm
rather a believer
in this
it is much easier for people to
understand what's going on when sort of
everything is there and when there isn't
hidden state and the hidden state could
be in variables which store data or it
could be in this program counter thing
which you kind of throw around and
change and have go-to's and so on and i
think that's a a thing which uh is is
it's sort of interesting because
in a sense
functional programming and so on is
extremely natural you know i've shown it
to lots of kids and so on who get it
very quickly
but there are aspects of it that get
quite abstract um as and where
they're not immediately self-evident to
people it's a little bit like what
happens in mathematics there are some
things which are you know which anybody
can reinvent
and there are some things like algebra
and calculus and so on which the average
person is not going to reinvent
and where you just have to kind of learn
it and it has a bit of abstraction and
it's one of the achievements of our
civilization so to speak so figure those
things out but you have to learn it
and the idea oh i can just muddle
through writing programs without ever
learning this little piece of
abstraction that was figured out
that eventually doesn't work i mean you
can get a certain distance with
functional programming without ever
thinking about that but there's a point
at which when you think start thinking
about pure anonymous functions and so on
where the lambda functions all those
kinds of things but just a little bit of
abstraction that you need to understand
just like you do to do algebra and
calculus and so on unfortunately a lot
of education about programming is is
sort of deeply misguided in this
direction of let's teach them loops
let's teach them program counters
effectively and things like that which
is something that is in a sense quite
it's it's
it's the the thing that actually is
worth teaching is the few abstract ideas
that really give you tremendous mileage
in being able to understand kind of
high-level programming and and people
tend to be like oh no no that's too
complicated but actually it's it's
actually a lot simpler than for example
the corresponding concepts in
mathematics which lots of educational
effort is spent on trying to communicate
uh it was a question related to a
previous thing did general systems
theory and systems theory die out and
why
yes they did pretty much die out um
there was a
there was a kind of a general systems
theory
society
that existed prospered in the 1950s and
60s
there was a person called ludwig van um
bertalanthi i think
i get that all the
syllables he was he was sort of a big
big figure in that whole thing um
you know it got
i think it got in some sense
very tied up with kind of political
social political
economic
issues
and i think it it part of what happened
was that it got to be applied to
kind of model the world
and particularly there was a thing
called the club of rome which was in the
1960s which was an attempt
to um
to make a general economic model of the
world where you could just figure out
what was going to happen in the world
it was not a success
and i think that that
caused a lack of confidence in these
kinds of approaches now i think there
are certain economic models that people
have
you don't hear so much about them
although certainly people are running
such models
that have kind of many components and
there's input output models and there's
you know there's there's flows of this
and that from here to there and that's
sort of a model of the of the economy of
of some area or the world or whatever
else you don't hear so much about those
kinds of things they were not hugely
successful i mean there was a time when
people thought oh we've got cybernetics
we've got the emergence of sort of early
ai
pretty soon we're going to solve the
world
didn't work
and
you know it didn't work i think for
fundamental scientific reasons
a little bit of common sense would have
also told you it's a harder problem than
you might have might at first have
imagined you know sometimes sometimes
these things sometimes once you have
some methodology you just get to be able
to solve everything it's all good i mean
people have had that idea back in the
early 1800s right there was this idea of
social physics to try and
solve the structure of society as people
like newton had solved the motion of
planets
that was also not successful um but uh
that was um uh you know i think this
sort of systems theory thing kind of
came out of that general approach now
now some pieces of that have kind of
turned into some aspects of the kind of
complexity complex systems world you
know my own efforts in kind of launching
that field in the 1980s uh really
revolved around this idea of of the
discovery that simple programs can do
very complicated things but there's sort
of a different branch of that that came
out of the systems theory area which was
really about there are these systems
with very complicated sets of components
can we understand how those work
i think things happened with there were
things like second order cybernetics
second order cybernetics was well
cybernetics was about you have a control
system for a thing
second order cybernetics had to do with
the observer of the system is
uh is is also part of what is being
controlled in the system and so on now
actually i've been interested in what
was done in second order cybernetics
recently because of my efforts in this
multi-computational paradigm and this
observer theory that i'm trying to build
so i dusted off a bunch of the books
that i have about second order
cybernetics and so on tried to look at
them
i have to say they were not they did not
make to me today
uh particularly informative reading um
they really were were kind of
fairly
uh
a lot of rhetoric
um and not uh methodology or formalism
that seemed to be um
uh seemed to be all that useful
but um uh yes i i think i think the
reason is that general systems theory
and died out was was sort of its
enmeshment with sort of economic kinds
of things and that not working out
systems theory that's an interesting
story because like where i live in
massachusetts for example there was an
effort to teach systems theory in all
schools i believe and i think that may
even still be going on um and it's kind
of a a systems thinking it's kind of a a
sort of a a branch i suppose of um a
little bit like computational thinking
but isn't really the same kind of thing
it's more about feedback loops and it's
more about you know can you make a flow
chart to represent these things in the
world
um and you know it just it just didn't
really get
i would say
a um
that became a thing that turned into
well perhaps to some extent
it turned into the evolution of things
like the logo programming language from
the 60s turned into things like scratch
which is all about essentially making
flowchart like sequences and so on and
maybe that's in a sense what what this
sort of educational branch of systems
theory might have turned into
um i would say that the the more kind of
large-scale let's study systems
that's partly turned into systems
engineering which is a whole
sort of very industrial branch of
engineering that has to do with well
like our product will from system
modeler is an example of something in
that space
where what one's doing is describing
essentially diagrammatically
the way that a large system you know a
jet engine a gas turbine something like
that works maybe they have 50 000
components and one's describing how each
cog connects to each other cog and then
once turning that all into a giant
collection of essentially
essentially differential algebraic
equations um and then having methods to
solve those things that's a very sort of
that's a a perfectly energetic area
systems engineering um but that's it
gets very mathematical whereas systems
theory
was much more on the structure of the
flowchart kind of side of things rather
than the let's write down you know a
million differential equations to
represent this thing
but that's uh that's kind of part of the
evolution another thing that came out of
that a little bit out of the flow
charting kind of thing was things like
uml um which is a a way of representing
it's kind of the sort of
sort of uh advanced form of flowcharts
that's a way that i think it's
particularly popular in things like
maybe aerospace but particularly defense
industry and so on of a way of sort of
representing large systems and kind of
the interdependencies of those large
systems um again that that feeds back to
the very original use of flowcharts and
things like factory automation where
one's interested in what's the
interdependence of these different
activities that's happening in something
like a factory
um
yeah so so that's an interesting point
from puts here so we modeled computers
after factory production lines and
that's how we ended up with imperative
programming i guess that's true i never
really thought about that before i i
best i guess that's true
um
and putz is also asking does functional
programming encounters liberation from
the von neumann style i think so i think
the the real issue is are you dealing
with sort of the program counter as a
thing and sort of loops and seeing
there's a piece of code here that you're
now executing as opposed to just
evaluating functions and so on oh david
says here that fred brooks is is listed
still alive that's that's good that's
good to hear
um
the um
uh let's see
um
okay there's a question from nick does
the scientific software development have
a different development practice
from the kinds of things that are done
in
in kind of
generic systems programming
it has tended to have
and that's partly because
the difficulty of writing algorithm is
different from the difficulty of writing
a transaction processing system
in a transaction processing system
typically
there are
there might be some you know non-trivial
algorithms somewhere but that's not the
main story the main story is just lots
and lots of details about you know what
happens if the customer
is uh you know
in this country and with a with a
conversion rate that doesn't work to
this and what happens if the person you
know cancels their credit card between
the time when they place the order and
this happens and so on it's a lot of
kind of details associated with what if
this or that circumstance happens in the
world and that type of programming tends
to need a sort of management of a
complexity of detail of how different
parts of
the code relate to each other whereas
algorithmic programming tends to be much
more there is a a single hard thing
you've got to figure out how are you
going to enumerate you know how are you
going to compute how many colors you
have to put down on the nodes of a graph
or something and that's a much more
integrated much more uh sort of it's a
it's a it's a piece of code that tends
to have much more interdependence than
well there is interdependence between
you know what happens if the customer
cancels their credit card versus you
know how does the shipping manifest get
produced for this
but it's a different kind of
interdependence it's not this kind of
interwoven algorithmic interdependence i
think what we see in world language and
in sort of the computational language
there that the need for for
for language design is is rather
informed by the fact that we are dealing
with these kinds of algorithmic kinds of
issues and you can use you can leverage
the language design that was developed
for those purposes for these more kind
of in a sense mundane programming tasks
but it's it's sort of held to a higher
standard because it's got to deal with
kind of the algorithmic case
and you know in our own company for
example uh yes we we use all kinds of
tools for um optimizing development
process um and uh
many of them written in wolverine
language itself um quite a lot of those
tools probably look rather different
from the tools that are used by people
who are um just you know implement all
the tentacles of this giant transaction
system actually in our own company we've
been rebuilding our erp system
that's our main sort of transaction
processing system over the last few
years uh using wolfram language and so
on and it's been interesting to see
the um i'm not sure i yet have a kind of
meta thing to say about that project and
kind of seeing it's
it is it is made vastly simpler by the
fact that it leverages the kind of
high-level symbolic language design that
we have in wolverine language that has
cut out
huge swaths of what would otherwise be
kind of traditional programming
complexity so it's a it's a that's sort
of using in a sense the algorithmic
programming paradigm on something which
is a more traditional kind of i.t
uh systems programming kind of task and
i think
i don't yet have a good meta thing to
say about kind of uh how those how those
different paradigms fit together but i i
i sense that there is a a different and
emergent kind of paradigm that has to do
with high-level symbolic programming as
applied to these traditional kinds of
sort of just many many details
transaction type type problems
um
there's a question
here
uh
let's see
um
oh the question from puts here about
flow chart descriptions flow charts a
very old idea that's a very old idea
it's not part of modern computer science
it predated it predated the existence of
electronic computers
um
let's see
well there's a question here let me
address this one this is from uh
saumon
um
about education teaching programming
uh
how higher level languages abstract more
and more away from the core metal and
will generations of programmers
understand the fundamentals or not
here's an observation that i made oh
maybe 15 years ago now i was very
disappointed by this one it's like
people who get eecs undergraduate
degrees
do they know how to use an oscilloscope
and i i had my first encounters with
people who had those kinds of degrees
from good universities it's like this is
an oscilloscope and they're like really
i've never used one of those
so you know there is an advance of
technology that happens
that um
is
uh
okay so one thing to say is as a
civilization we learn more and more
there's more and more knowledge in our
civilization
that means in principle if people want
to learn
stuff that's known to our civilization
it's going to take them longer and
longer to do that because there's more
and more knowledge
and in a sense you know you could expect
that at any given time there's just tons
of you know this you could spend sort of
an infinite time being school because
there's so much knowledge in our
civilization
what's the count of ailing force
the the counter balancing thing is in
addition to there being more knowledge
there's also more abstraction
there's also more oh you don't need to
know that because it is all uh
encompassed in this one fact so you know
instead of learning separately all the
different forms of syllogisms for logic
that people did in the middle ages and
they learned them by rote you know the
barbara structure of an argument the
celerant structure of an argument and so
on people realize that well actually all
you need to know is about and or not and
you can construct everything from that
so sort of a higher level of abstraction
that meant that you didn't have to learn
all of those rote memorization or
whatever it was all those details of how
things worked at the lower level and
it's the same thing i think in general
with the advance of education that at
any given time there's kind of the what
you need to know
in um uh you know that there's sort of a
frontier that is stuff that's worth the
humans knowing and there's stuff below
that that's sort of been abstracted away
and you have to have that abstraction
away otherwise you're just going to be
drowned in all of the knowledge that's
accumulated in in our civilization so to
speak
so
when it comes to to computers and how
computers work and so on um you know i
think and i've said this multiple times
and let me not go into this in
tremendous detail but the the key skill
is kind of computational thinking and
how do you think computationally about
anything in the world
and that thinking computationally about
something has nothing to do with knowing
how the op codes in the assembly
language of a computer work
it it's nothing to do with that
computation is a paradigm for thinking
about the world
it could even be applied even if we
didn't have computers
it's a way of kind of structuring our
thinking about the world and you know
i've spent lots of time building our
full-scale computational language to
kind of provide people a language for
talking about things computationally for
saying oh i want to
take i don't know this um
geo distance between this and this and i
want to
take that mapped over this collection of
different cities et cetera et cetera et
cetera this is kind of the ideas of sort
of a a computational process which we
could describe and even execute as
humans but it is something where we now
have this paradigm just as mathematics
provided kind of a paradigm for thinking
about things and the notation for
mathematics that we have is like 400
years old or so
that provided kind of this framework for
thinking and presenting and
communicating things
so similarly computation provides a
framework for thinking about presenting
communicating and an extra piece having
your computer know what you're talking
about
and that's a really critical thing to
educate people about something which as
yet the engines are poorly started on
that kind of education that is you know
if you ask what is going to be the skill
that somebody can learn when they're a
kid that will be useful to them forever
it's you know learn the computational
methods so to speak
learn
how to think about things
computationally and i i will have to say
that um you know in in in full
disclosure so to speak i think the
computational language that i just spent
40 years building is the best path we
have right now to have people actually
learn this kind of computational method
and there really isn't much else because
it's not like the sort of traditional
programming languages where you're
learning something much more detailed
about how computers operate
so you know i think that that skill is a
critical skill it's like the skill of
being able to write a piece of english
or something like that
um and uh you know that's the um that's
a clearly a super valuable skill that's
the thing we should really care about in
education now in terms of how do
computers work
well
you know how important is it to know at
a low level how computers work
i don't think it's terribly important i
mean i think it's very interesting
and but i don't think it's terribly
important
i think that a small segment of the
population uh is going to care a lot and
is going to be the people who invent the
next generation of how computers work
and those people absolutely should have
them have the opportunity to learn about
these things but the typical person you
know learning assembly language learning
how uh you know the the memory hierarchy
in computers works
learning how you know the opcode decoder
tree of the cpu chip works i mean i
think it's all interesting stuff but i
would certainly not claim that people
need to know it i mean it's it's like
it's like you shouldn't drive a car
unless you know how spark plugs work
that might have been true in the early
1900s
when you often had to you know open up
the hood and start jiggling with things
but in today's world uh you know i i i
i don't know the car i've had the last
few years i don't think i've ever opened
its hood now that i think about it i
don't even know what it looks like
inside um and uh
you know and i wouldn't expect that if i
did that there will be much that would
be sort of user accessible so to speak
um so i think the answer as i see it is
it's a you know i think that in learning
you know computation as a methodology as
a way of thinking critically important
really really worth teaching people one
of the things like english writing that
is sort of guaranteed to actually be a
thing that will be useful to people
throughout their lives
um the um uh writing whatever language
you write in but but um uh you know i
think that there is a different thing
which is the kind of cultural knowledge
of computation
just like one learns history or one
should learn history um i think that
learning the kind of the history of
ideas the history of technology around
computers it's interesting i don't think
people teach that yet they probably
should and teaching kind of how
computers fundamentally work is kind of
part of that cultural knowledge just
like you know what should you learn in
education why are you doing education in
the first place it's like kind of
learning about the world and so on
and part of that story is about the
story of technology and about things
like how computers work but in terms of
should your average kid be able to go in
and
look at the operating system look at the
source code of their operating system
and be able to say oh that's a you know
that's a place where this interrupt
handler has not been correctly
configured to do this or that
that's not a real world um i mean that's
for the people who are going to become
professional software engineers and who
are going to learn a big pile of of
stuff um you know the the computational
method at a high level absolutely that's
for everybody but you know the under the
hood stuff that's for people who are
interested in software engineering i
think
um
let's see
uh
well okay i'm just going to answer one
more question here i think because i'm
running out of time
um someone from x here
was i ever involved in the development
of a kind of software that now you think
might be morally questionable in some
sense
oh gosh
that's a complicated story because
you know you build tools people use them
for all kinds of things
usually in our situation
we put out tools and
you know
nobody we don't know what people use
them for and
sometimes
sometimes we find out they were used for
some really
purpose where we say i really feel good
about that that's terrific sometimes
they were used for purposes where like
oh they really they did that with it you
know it's something that is very hard to
um
uh to to sort of distinguish and
sometimes things that seemed good at one
time became bad at another time and so
on i'll tell you one story maybe i've
told this before on some some live
stream about i'll tell you actually
maybe two stories about about this one
one story um this was maybe 1984.
so middle of the cold war
and i was working on all kinds of things
about physics and computers and so on
and i was interested in uh
i i just
was curious about neutrinos and quantum
mechanics neutrinos are these particles
that don't interact very much so you
know neutrinos can go all the way
through the earth without interacting
but you can detect them to some extent
i thought i had might have come up with
a method for doing coherent detection of
neutrinos that is increasing by factors
of trillions the sensitivity of neutrino
detectors
using oh
uh superfluid helium 3 um and
as a way to kind of have neutrinos
interact not just atom by atom but with
whole blocks of atoms the kind of way
that a radio wave interacts with a radio
antenna it doesn't do it sort of
electron by electron it does it kind of
collectively coherently across all those
electrons so i thought i might have
figured out a way to detect uh neutrinos
in a similar kind of coherent fashion
with high sensitivity okay so
that sounds like oh cool scientific idea
yeah well the problem is okay every
nuclear reactor produces neutrinos
and one set of nuclear reactors
that were
out and about i would say in the world
then and now are on nuclear submarines
and one of the big stories of the cold
war was this kind of notion of you know
both sides have lots of nuclear
submarines prowling around under the
oceans and the other side doesn't know
where the other
you know sides nuclear submarines are
and um uh so that because they're deep
in the ocean and that you know they just
they're they're submerged for long
periods of time and nobody knows where
they are um
that so if you can detect neutrinos and
you can detect them very sensitively
from satellites you could have detected
nuclear submarines and so that's like oh
you know that's an issue what do you you
know if it is the case that there is a
technological idea where somebody could
build this detector put in a satellite
and then all these nuclear submarines
that everybody thought were in secret
places it's like now we know where they
all are what do you do with such a piece
of knowledge and so i really agonized
about this for for a couple of days and
i was actually
very glad when it turned out that um
that that particular idea for detecting
neutrinos just can't work
and um you know i because i really
didn't know what to do about it it's
like what do you do with with that type
of information and um uh
you know i think i i might have a
slightly different point of view today
than i did then um but uh it's it's one
of these things where
um
it's a uh there was a case where where
it's a
you know where you invent something and
where you don't where it's going to turn
out i would say another example of that
for me is this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
this idea that you can specify the rules
for something but
you uh to know what will happen is
something that can involve an
irreducible amount of computation you
might just have to follow the rules step
by step to see what happens you can't
kind of jump ahead and say i'm smarter
than that system i can jump and say this
is what's going to happen in the end
computational irreducibility has just
many many many many consequences one of
the good news consequences is it's kind
of what in a sense
makes kind of uh life mean something at
some level because it's what means that
it what it's what the passage of time is
an inexorable irreducible thing it's not
something where you can say and the end
result of all these years i lived is 42
and that's and i can kind of jump ahead
and i don't have to go through all that
time to get to that answer it's the kind
of the reason that the passage of time
has meaning
but it has another consequence which i
you know i i knew that early on back and
i invented this kind of idea back in the
1980s um early 1980s it's kind of a idea
closely related to things like
goodwill's theorem and halting problems
but it's a kind of more fine-grained
version of that more applicable to kind
of uh scientific kinds of questions
so
anyway that's computational
irreducibility i thought of it in part
as a limitation on what science can
deduce because it tells you you can't
predict what's going to happen you can't
just jump ahead to predict what's going
to happen you have to just follow each
step and see what happens that's an
important ultimate limitation on science
that there's a lot to say about and i
understood these things about free will
and about the passage of time and so on
i understand of that stuff and i i
thought of the of computational
irreducibility as both a limitation on
science and a an enablement
of um uh of kind of um
um
of this kind of um the meaning of time
so to speak but what i didn't predict
is that years later
um
the uh
you know uh
uh in the invention of of of bitcoin by
satoshi nakamoto
um
that um
that the uh
that this idea of computational
irreducibility for for i i
i i have
i have a a strong belief let's say that
that um the inventor of bitcoin had read
a bunch of my work on computational
irreducibility and my new kind of
science book and things like that
um and um
uh the um
this idea of bitcoin uh mining
where you're sort of um uh doing this
irreducible computation to kind of uh
you know
give evidence that you're sort of
committing to value or something that
idea i think came out of computational
irreducibility i mean it also had a more
proximate cause and various kinds of
hashing algorithms and things like this
but the conceptual idea
i think not certain hard to know we
don't we don't uh officially know who
satoshi nakamoto uh uh
uh has been
um the uh
i think that um um
the the the the but this notion that
this thing that sort of a piece of basic
science would turn into
this uh
bitcoin mining where you're burning you
know the power outlet of power output of
italy or something in people uh doing
sort of in a sense meaningless
computations just for the sake of doing
irreducible computation the fact that
that scientific idea had that
consequence was something so far away
from anything that i had imagined when i
originally developed that idea it's kind
of a it's kind of a sort of a sobering
tale at some level um because it's like
you just can't predict and in a sense
computational irreducibility itself
makes the point you just can't predict
what's going to happen
all right i should wrap up here um and
uh thanks for lots of interesting
interesting questions here i'm actually
doing another
thing that will be live streamed which
is uh
a software design review
um coming up in a few minutes
but um
thanks for joining us here
and uh
see you again another time